لقد أبلغنا أن المسؤولين
داخل أوكرانيا وخارجها يعترفون الآن أن
التقدم في الجريمة يأتي بشكل
أبطأ مما كانوا يأملون، لماذا هذا هو السبب في
بعض التحديات
التي يواجهونها هناك
أه نعم صباح الخير
أم
الهجمات بطيئة جدًا جدًا
بالفعل أه لأن
القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية
والمصطلحات البسيطة في الأساس ليست قوية بما يكفي
بعد وكان
لدى القوات الروسية
قدر كبير من الوقت لإعداد
الدفاعات
وإذا نظرت إلى الخريطة فنحن  نتحدث
عن الدفاعات المجهزة والتي يصل عمقها في بعض
الأماكن إلى 30 كيلومترًا وهي
عملية حرب كبيرة وصعبة
لاختراق تلك الدفاعات خاصة أه
عندما لا يتمتع أي من الطرفين بتفوق جوي كما
تعلم الروس يبدو أنهم أفضل
في الدفاع عنهم وبعد ذلك لقد  لقد
تم الهجوم
أم العقيدة العسكرية الروسية هي إلى حد
كبير من أعلى إلى أسفل موجهة من الأعلى
بينما في الدوائر الغربية
هناك مبادرات أكثر بكثير مسموح بها
على مستويات القيادة المبتدئة أه تشبه إلى حد كبير
النموذج الألماني خلال
الحرب العالمية الثانية الذي قامت به كل من الولايات المتحدة وبريطانيا
و  لقد
اعتمد حلفاء الناتو الآخرون ذلك، هذا هو ما
نحن فيه في الوقت الحالي،
فالإمبراطوريون ليسوا أقوياء بما فيه الكفاية
والروس أقوياء جدًا في الوقت الحالي،
حسنًا فقط لإعطاء مثال واحد على أحد
التحديات على سبيل المثال عندما
يخترق الأوكرانيون حقول الألغام من أجل  على سبيل
المثال، يمكن للروس أن
يزرعوها مرة أخرى، أعني ما هو تأثير
ذلك بشكل
جيد، أعني أنه صحيح تمامًا
أن اختراق حقل ألغام هو
عملية معقدة وصعبة للغاية،
وليس المهندسون فقط هم الذين يتدخلون أولاً
وينظفون العقول من  بالطريقة التي يجب أن
يكونوا محميين ضد
النيران الأرضية والهجوم الجوي،
وبمجرد إخلاء طريق عبر
حقل الألغام أو مسار جزئي عبر
حقل الألغام، يكون لدى الروس
القدرة على إطلاق ألغام عن بعد
على الجزء الذي تم تطهيره وفي
الواقع  وراء المهندسين لذلك فهو
معقد وخطير بشكل لا يصدق